they say they're pro-life they say
they're american they say they're
patriotic they say save the children but
they stand back and watch children get
slaughtered time after time after time
this will not be the last time that the
gqp has blood on their hands last week
it was a [ __ ] grocery store and a
church yesterday was a school second
third fourth graders teachers the
shooter in yuvali was not a lone gunman
he had the help of governor abbott the
nra senator ted cruz john cornyn you
weak [ __ ] oh i'm gonna back out
of the nra cause it looks bad you know
what looks bad you know what looks
really [ __ ] bad john cornyn you weak
piece of [ __ ] dead children's bodies all
over the floor of a school that's what
we should do we should make the governor
and the senators and all the gqp go mop
up those children off the floor there's
a law you can [ __ ] pass i think the
country is sick and [ __ ] tired of
this [ __ ] this is america folks the land
of the armed and the home of the broken
every parent in the in america this
morning was nervous about sending their
children to a school think about it for
a second i know you hugged your children
when they came home i know you held them
as long as they would let you hold them
mental health mental illness we need
mental health yeah we are going to need
a lot of mental health in this [ __ ]
country can you imagine the mental
health care that the other students the
other staff members the teachers the
police officers the [ __ ] parents of
the dead slaughtered children
you pieces a weak [ __ ] and you're i'm
not gonna let you look away we have
voters in this country that only only
pick out a few [ __ ] issues and that's
what they vote on and every single time
it's to take away your rights your right
to your uterus your right to your
[ __ ] vote and your right to your
children's safety you don't think we
have the [ __ ] right to live in this
country you don't think our children
have the right to learn without being
scared that they're gonna be [ __ ]
mowed down torn apart by a
semi-automatic rifle because you got a
boner for guns so you can protect your
tv and you can shoot politicians you
dirty [ __ ] you dirty
[ __ ] nope i'm not gonna shut up
i'm not gonna stop talking when we're in
a country where a goddamn gun has more
[ __ ] rights than a woman's uterus
it's time it is so it is [ __ ] time if
you're not ready to go to the [ __ ]
polls and vote every single one of these
[ __ ] out you're doing it wrong
this morning i don't care if you're
[ __ ] republican if you're a goddamn
democrat i don't care if you're a
[ __ ] conservative if you're a parent
in this country a [ __ ] grandparent in
this country you should be ready
tomorrow to vote these [ __ ] out
they are gonna go to the [ __ ] nra
conference in texas and cheer cheer the
slaughter children yesterday that's what
they're gonna do and we're just gonna
stand here and let them do it
take our democracy away from us make
this into an autocracy i'm not i'm gonna
keep yelling into this microphone i'm
gonna keep motivating you to stay
[ __ ] pissed it's time to fight with
the ballot enough is enough of this [ __ ]
when will it [ __ ] end when can we
send our kids to school to learn and not
be slaughtered torn apart by a piece of
weaponry that we manufacture in this
country so some [ __ ] dude or some
dumb [ __ ] conservative somewhere can
take a picture of it in front of a
[ __ ] christmas tree you dumb
[ __ ] i've had about a [ __ ]
enough of this stupid [ __ ] where the
minority ideology in this country gets
to tell us what the [ __ ] to do ninety
percent ninety percent nine out of ten
[ __ ] people realize it's a good
idea to do a goddamn background check
before you give someone a goddamn weapon
that is designed to kill multiple human
beings 9 out of 10 people already
[ __ ] realize it joe manchin says oh
i'll do anything anything i can do to
stop children from being slaughtered in
schools well do something [ __ ]
[ __ ] your career [ __ ] you being a
senator who cares about your [ __ ]
votes stop giving a [ __ ] about your own
goddamn power those children had no
[ __ ] power not a god outer power to
stop that gunman those [ __ ] cops had
no power to stop that gunman good guy
with a gun gave me a [ __ ] break [ __ ]
you good guy with a gun you son of a
[ __ ] ken paxton you [ __ ] so you
want you want [ __ ] teachers you want
teachers to be police officers and the
police officers can't even stop these
[ __ ] with these weapons that's
the intent the intent when they [ __ ]
manufacture this stuff is to make sure
that you are not stopped with the gun
what don't you get how can't we [ __ ]
understand this it's time to vote every
one of those [ __ ] out we need
to be single-issue voters in this
country right now not yesterday not
tomorrow not next week right mother
[ __ ] now one issue voters and the
issue is [ __ ] you gqp [ __ ] you that's
our issue that's it right there their
republican vote them the [ __ ] out they
want your children slaughtered they
don't give a [ __ ] about you they don't
want your rights taken away from you
they don't give a [ __ ]
about you you dumb [ __ ] and
until they do that is our one issue [ __ ]
you gqp [ __ ] you that's your issue go
vote go engage give money don't give
thoughts and prayers
type in five dollars to your local
[ __ ] congressman who can beat that
[ __ ] gqp or who's gonna [ __ ]
have blood on his hands from the nra who
won't [ __ ] stomach stomach even
standing in front of a goddamn
microphone and talking about the
slaughter of children that we can stop
we can stop this we can stop it you can
stop it go vote them the [ __ ] out if
you're not registered go get registered
right now if your [ __ ] family if your
[ __ ] community members are not
registered now is the time right now not
tomorrow now today commit to the one
issue of [ __ ] you gqp that's the issue
one only one you're out of here
[ __ ] you have proven that you
have no intent to govern no intent to
put american people in front of your
power even slaughtered [ __ ] children
mental health get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] you need a [ __ ] head
check you sons of [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
pissed and i'll stay pissed until these
[ __ ] are gone they don't want
to create policy that prevents children
from being slaughtered well fine we'll
vote them the [ __ ] out we
we can't even we can't even get these
[ __ ] to agree what 90 percent
of people in this country believe that
yes it is really [ __ ] boneheaded to
not do a background check on a piece of
equipment that is designed to kill human
beings multiple human beings what are
you gonna do that's my question what are
you gonna do i'm talking to you the
audience what are you going to do you
got many options you can give money to
campaigns i'll tell you one [ __ ]
option if you're in texas right now i'd
be giving every [ __ ] nickel out of
your goddamn couch every penny out of
your couch to better o'rourke every
[ __ ] nickel greg abbott is the reason
why this happened cheering cheering that
anyone can get a gun anywhere anytime
cheering it tweeting out oh man we
really are in a [ __ ] competition with
other states to have as many guns on the
street as we possibly can have because
that's what makes us safe as you can see
yesterday the evidence is clear more
guns equals dead bodies and that's what
they want i was in junior high when
columbine happened i was about to go
into high school when the national news
was that high schools weren't safe your
classmates could come in and [ __ ]
murder you
and i lived in rural america where every
kid had access to guns every
[ __ ] had access to guns there
was guns in every household in rural
america now they weren't the weapons
that we have today because you gotta
remember in the 1990s there was the
assault weapons ban but we still
wondered when we go to high school are
we gonna have to dodge [ __ ] bullets
are we gonna have to hide under desk are
we gonna have to run from our classmates
in the cafeteria to save our [ __ ]
lives here we are over 20 years later
and they're still giving us the same old
[ __ ] good guy bad guy [ __ ] guns don't
kill people people kill people same old
[ __ ] same old [ __ ] and these politicians
buy it hook line sinker cause the nra
comes to them and says hey look
[ __ ] you don't vote with us
we'll vote you out and we got the voters
look at our register [ __ ] and they want
their power their power is way more
important than 19
19 children being stacked up like
cordwood in texas their power is way
more important than that duh in the
1990s after columbine happened the nra
wayne lapierre went to congress and
we're in support of background checks
we're supporting regulation but they
soon found out they soon found out that
mass shootings doesn't equal bad
business mass shootings equals good
business they can really stoke fear
inside of their small percentage their
small handful of people in this country
that believe this garbage and make them
go by guns because they're afraid the
government's going to take them well i'm
here to say to all you gun nuts out
there who think you [ __ ] want the
second amendment and have the second
amendment you better get to the
negotiating table [ __ ] fast quick
fast and in the hurry i don't know how
long this is gonna sustain especially
with me yelling and screaming i'm not
gonna stop i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not
going to stop you won't stop me try to
cancel me try to turn me off not gonna
happen i'm gonna yell and scream at
somebody i'm not gonna stop are you
gonna stop it's time to [ __ ] take our
[ __ ] country back it's time to vote
it's time to be one issue voters [ __ ]
you gqp [ __ ] you that's your [ __ ] one
issue they want to reign terror down on
your communities they want to strike
fear into the hearts of your children 19
children went to school yesterday
thinking that they'd ride the bus home
thinking that their parents would pick
them up thinking they were safe there's
even an armed cop at the school to keep
him safe the good guy with the gun there
he is trained with a badge licensed paid
for and because the republicans won't
pluck their heads out of their asses in
this country and realize it doesn't
matter if you have an armed guard at the
school it doesn't [ __ ] matter when
the person comes with better body armor
and a more efficient weapon to kill
human beings doesn't matter if you have
an armed guard it doesn't matter if
teachers have weapons they're just
targets at that point what's next can
paxton you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
gonna make sure every child every first
grader every kindergartner every second
grader has a semi-automatic raffle a
rifle slung over their back so they can
protect themselves when someone with a
piece of armory that you won't regulate
comes into a school and tears them to
pieces rips them to shreds with a war
machine huh is that what you want you
want the kids to be armed too i mean
that's the next step ken paxton you
[ __ ] where are you gonna go from
here it's time now is the time it was
time a long time ago columbine sandy
hook parkland [ __ ] last week had a
grocery store in buffalo new york for
crying out [ __ ] loud america pluck
your head out of your [ __ ] ass and
realize that your vote matters your
ballot matters your voice matters it
[ __ ]
matters you're the one that goes to the
poll you're the one that talks to your
friends you're the one that says the
things that you need to say to your
community members to motivate them to
make sure these scumbags do not have
their hands on our policy because their
bloody hands are all over it and they're
not going to stop they're not going to
we're going to watch we're going to look
at and watch a lot of really [ __ ]
gross takes on a whole stack of dead
children's bodies this morning and again
maybe that is the solution maybe we
should pass a law to where when there is
a school shooting and there's dead
children that our politicians who make
the policies about keeping those schools
safe have to go mop up mop up the
carnage and clean it up themselves maybe
maybe just maybe their power won't be as
important it's enough of this [ __ ]
america's pissed parents are pissed
teachers are pissed this didn't have to
happen we are doing this to ourselves we
are yes we you must become one issue
voters now right now and it's to vote
out anyone who has an r next to their
goddamn name all the way down to the
[ __ ] dog catcher if they even
have a stench a stench just the whiff of
the nra the republican party trumpism
and maca vote them the [ __ ] out it's
enough of this craziness even the ones
that are like oh well i'm not i'm not
queuing on crazy but that inner raced up
wink love that love that nope out [ __ ]
enough of it and it's up to us it's up
to you i'm talking to you now it is up
to you not just to go vote but you have
to give money to these campaigns if you
can afford it you have to talk to your
community members you have to organize
you have to organize against these
[ __ ] fascists you don't think that
this is fascism they love this they love
this stuff ted cruz is practically
laughing practically laughing when he
blames the shooting that happened
yesterday on democrats as if democrats
haven't tried their damnedest in every
[ __ ] way possible in every legislator
in the entire country to either pass
legislation that would make sure these
weapons do not end up in the hands or
even manufactured and they have either
been stopped by republicans or they
can't stop the legislation that puts
these guns on the street in texas as
long as you have a heartbeat and you're
[ __ ] breathing you get to have a
murder weapon you get to have a machine
of war so you can go into an elementary
school and mow down and murder 19
children why not it's texas pew pew pew
pew i have a lot more faith in texas net
i believe there's a hell of a lot of
people in texas that do not want that to
be texas oh but tony people in texas
they love their guns more than their
children more than their community
members more than the teachers who teach
their children more than the police
officers that have to [ __ ] protect
the school with gunfire are you
listening they had to send a swat team
to a school because greg abbott just was
in a competition of how many guns he can
sell in the state of texas now is the
time right [ __ ] now to show them that
they will not do this to our country and
you can do that by being a one-issue
voter and that issue is [ __ ] you gop
[ __ ] you vote them the [ __ ] out it's
time right now
if you want this to stop if you want to
make sure that a woman's uterus has more
rights than a [ __ ] firearm in this
country if you want to make sure that
your children have the right to go to
school and to be safe to not be scared
that someone's gonna come in and cut
them up with a goddamn weapon of war
that the police officers don't have to
worry about protecting a goddamn
elementary school from war-like gunfire
it's not a school zone anymore it's a
[ __ ] war zone and only we can change
it it's up to us they're not going to do
it you think republicans are going to do
this hell to the no they're not going to
do this republicans are not going to do
this they are not going to change a
goddamn thing not a [ __ ] thing if you
think republicans are going to get off
their asses and do something you just
look at joe manchin who relies on
republicans to vote for him he's like
i'll do anything anything possible
anything in the world that saved
children at schools from being shot by
guns what about the filibuster mr
mansion oh well i can't do that
i mean when i mean anything i mean
nothing and he's a democrat who relies
on republicans to vote for him you think
the republicans who rely on republicans
to vote for them are going to do
something get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] they are not going to do a god
damn thing not a [ __ ] thing not a
[ __ ] thing and i ain't gonna put up
with this though democrats won't do [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's a goddamn bill right
now hr8 sitting sitting there to be
voted on for background just background
checks just just that that's not even
enough to [ __ ] stop the gun violence
in this country but only just just that
just that [ __ ] thing that ninety
percent of the country agree on yeah you
should probably pass a background check
to get a [ __ ] weapon that mows down
dozens of human beings you might you
might want to do that this is what
happens when we have the minority of
ideology controlling parts of our
government and that is up to you and you
may say oh well tony my district is
rigged i'm in a jerry who gives a [ __ ]
stop with the excuses are you tired of
republicans excuses are you tired of
that [ __ ] good don't have your own don't
have your own excuse now is not the time
to have excuses they're taking away
macbooks they want to marry your
children and they want to have them
slaughtered in schools yesterday is a
sad day in our country and tomorrow will
be too there'll be another one don't
worry it'll be another sad day you'll
shed tears they'll send tots and pairs
they'll talk about how oh it's a tragedy
and mental illness and constitutional
rights and blah blah blah blah blah
tomorrow will be another sad day because
they won't they're not gonna do a thing
they're not gonna do a [ __ ] thing but
you can you sure sell cam you have the
power so if you find these races where
you have one of these nra gun nuts in
the race give to their opponent campaign
for their opponent put a bumper sticker
on sign in your hell buy a goddamn flag
wave it from your [ __ ] pickup truck
whatever it takes folks whatever it
takes to make sure our children are safe
how is this how is this such a hard idea
anything anything to keep our [ __ ]
children safe just as real rich that we
have to take a lecture from the people
who say save the children and we can't
even we can't even get these [ __ ]
idiots to stop them from slaughtering
our children